we haven't even got to the second week
of January and you're already starting
to fall off your money goals what is
going on man you're feeling the
resistance it's getting difficult things
are starting to get real and you could
really use some encouragement some
motivation probably some practical tips
you need to learn a few things I have
got just the antidote for you on
Thursday January 11th we are hosting a
free live stream it's at 700 p.m. this
is the kick in the booty that you need
to keep making progress and keep moving
forward with your money goals because
listen when 2025 hits you are not going
to be broke any longer you will finally
have gotten control over your life over
your money and you are going to be a new
person but this is how you do it you've
got to get involved you got to get into
it you got to register for the live
stream and when you do we're giving
$1,000 away to 10 different winners I
want to see you online at that live
stream I'll see you January 11th